في ايران يسعى النظامه للالتفاف على عجزه
في كبح الاحتجاجات المستمره في البلاد
فاخرج من جديد حبال المشانق واصدر اليوم
حكما باعدام احد المتظاهرين المعتقلين في
محافظه مادران شمال طهران بالتزامن افاد
التقارير بنشر السلطات الايرانيه شرطه
الاخلاق في شوارع البلاد وضوابط الحجاب
الالزاميه فبحسب وكاله انباء فارس اعلن
مسؤول في الشرطه الايرانيه عوده الرسائل
النصيه التي تتعلق بالزاميه الحجاب لاصحاب
السيارات في جميع انحاء البلاد وقالت
الوكاله ان رسائل نصيه ترسل لتذكر اصحاب
السيارات التي يتم فيها خلع الحجاب وتشيره
تقارير على مواقع التواصل الى عوده شرطه
الاخلاق في شوارع طهران التي كان نائب
العام
وتاتي عوده انتشار شرطه الاخلاق في ظل
الاستمرار الاحتجاجات في انحاء البلاد
واستنتشر نمي المكثف من الشرطه الايرانيه
في بعض الملاطق
[موسيقى]